no girl I think you might like my best
friend's granddaughter Oh Jack she's the
sweetest thing so that's how Jack
Rebecca started dating well it's just
one of the things we get to learn
tonight on the season finale of this is
us and make sure that you have a box of
tissues ready because there is one other
thing we might learn and it is gonna be
crushing how Jack loses his life
Jack are you home I miss you and I wish
you were here I wish I was there I love
you
of course fans of the show already know
Jack wasn't home because he with a few
empty beer cans next dam is actually
making the two-hour drive to see Rebekah
show that leads to the theory that Jack
dies in a drunk driving accident you
know the show explores life and in life
there is death so you have to accept
that that's going to come these new
flashback scenes from tonight's finale
only add to the speculation jack tossing
one back having a drink with a friend
and then what appears to be the tube
pulled over by a cop past episodes even
foreshadowed alcohol was a problem the
drinking has to stop you have to rein it
in baby because I won't have it in my
house be a man and fix it other big
moments we'll see include Randall trying
to move on after his biological father's
death and what happens to Kevin after
this this is Ron right Ron Howard I'm
prepping a movie right now that I'm
gonna direct you would be perfect I
would this comes right after he's
rediscovered the love of his life Sophie
and they've reconnected it certainly
lends itself to some high drama doesn't
it after tonight it'll be six months
before the new season but don't worry
the cast is feeling the pain just like
we are well we were shooting all
together and it was like felt like the
last day of school when you're like oh
my god this is so exciting this is so
great everyone's kind of like just
having a great time and then when you go
home and you're driving home you're like
oh I'm gonna miss this we're putting
them through it a little bit and my
apology to you fans cuz we love you so
I'm asking you just bear with us bear
with the Pearson clan we'll get back to
you in a few months
you